First, very few people
are satisfied with the way
that their partner initiates sex.
And second, there are four distinct ways
that the erotic brain lights up.
I named them sensation,
sentiment, sexotic and surrender.
So what lights up your erotic brain?
Is it sensation?
The sensual side of sex.
What about sentiment?
Does your erotic brain light up
when you feel emotionally connected?
When you feel loved,
seen, important?
Or maybe you're sexotic.
You think sex.
Or then there is surrender.
Now, surrender, your erotic brain lights
up also when you think sex.
But it's coupled with letting
go of thought.
Discover which of the four ways
best lights up your erotic brain.